[Music]
all of this has come to a head because
of the international backlash uh you
know especially in the gulf countries
uh there are threats uh and calls to
boycott indian products you know envoys
and ambassadors have been summoned in
various countries you know these are
nations that the indian government has
spent a lot of time and energy building
close strategic ties with
foreign
[Music]
the bjp has benefited a lot from
mobilization against muslims
but in this instance there has been an
international uh price to pay i think
something like the qatar ministry is
summoning it's good because this is
nothing short of hate speech india has
one of the world's largest muslim
populations
so it has come to the notice of the
world that this is happening and i think
it will be harder for the official
uh
at least you cannot say all this
officially even if you are mobilizing
against muslims
you